i think this is a good decision by the
fda it's based on recently accumulated
data around the antibody or immune
response in immunocompromised people who
have a weakened immune system as you
mentioned cancer patients transplant
patients etc
so i think it's a good decision it tells
us a lot about where the science and
data are heading and i do believe that
we will this presages a decision about a
broader application of booster
immunizations you know it's not that
uncommon right tetanus shots have
boosters
and and i think we always had the
expectation that this might be the case
[Music]
and that was the commissioner the former
commissioner of the fda dr stephen hahn
on mornings with maria with me last week
on fox business praising the fda's
decision to authorize coveted boosters
for people with weakened immune systems
joining me right now is the president of
moderna he is the
leader of all research and development
at the company dr stephen hogue is here
dr hogue it's very good to see you this
morning thanks very much for spending
the time with us you heard dr han tell
us about the
need for a booster how much protection
does the modern vaccine give us and will
we all need a booster at some point
well it's important to contextualize
this in the face of the delta variant
and really the surge of cases we've seen
so
if you look over the course of the
summer i think we've all been surprised
by the steps the virus has taken to
evolve and get much much better in the
form of delta and infecting people and
that's really what's driving the surge
right now so the vaccines are really
effective and that's the good news in
fact if you look at the breakdown of
cases still almost overwhelmingly these
cases are in the unvaccinated people the
number one thing we got to do is get
those folks vaccinated but as you said
maria there is breakthrough clearly
starting to happen with the vaccine and
and delta poses a substantial threat to
all the vaccines and the durability of
that immunity
what do you make of these breakthrough
cases i mean anecdotally i have a few
friends that had been vaccinated but got
covered anyway
yeah it's well it's i think dr hahn said
it well it's it's not surprising that
immunity would decline over time uh for
a respiratory virus if you think about
it it's not that different than when you
get the common cold we're used to
getting the common cold every couple of
years and sometimes it can be a severe
cold and that's really actually a cousin
to the coronavirus that's currently
circulating so you would expect over
time that corona is going to be able to
reinfect and maybe cause a disease like
covet 19. i think the surprising thing
is that it's happening this quickly many
folks in this country are vaccinated
maybe six months ago and what we're
seeing is breakthrough cases starting to
emerge differentially across the
vaccines for sure but really starting to
emerge as a result of the delta variant
at about six to nine months and i think
that suggests we are going to need
booster vaccines to get through the
winter okay
i want to ask you more about this
because i know that the vaccine loses
some efficacy after six months let's
take a short break and then zero in on
the vaccine efficacy longer term and
then i want to ask you what else you're
developing with this mrna technology
including treating respiratory disease
as well as cancer we'll be right we'll
be right back with the president of
moderna dr stephen hogue stay with us
now our cdc and the
president administration won't even
acknowledge natural immunity
which is every bit as effective
as
getting the vaccination and between the
two about 85 percent of our population
has
immunity so we need to be dealing with
that and working with that and giving
people the actual numbers and letting
them make make decisions mandates
[Music]
and that was that was dr ben carson on
the program last month discussing
natural immunity he of course is a
specialist in uh neurology uh i'm back
with a dr stephen hogue from moderna so
dr ho how much immunity does a person
have if they've already had covid will
they need a booster shot as well
well i think we don't know we don't have
the data on it to be honest i think
we're still trying to develop data on
how much natural immunity protects you
just like we are with the vaccines but
we do know when we measure the level of
immunity in the blood of people who've
been infected it is lower than you're
seeing certainly with the madonna
vaccine or the pfizer vaccine which
would suggest that breakthrough cases
are going to happen with natural
immunity at least as soon as if not
sooner than you're going to see with
vaccines
this is this is fascinating and of
course i know that we're learning more
about this as as we live it um but
you're saying that we will you're not
surprised by these breakthrough cases
right but but you were surprised you
said a minute ago that it was happening
as soon as it was right
that's right i think i think again you'd
expect respiratory viruses to be able to
reinfect people hopefully not cause
severe disease like gobi 19 but it's
sort of the natural history of these
infections
i think the surprising thing that we're
all seeing right now is we're in the
middle of a global pandemic the virus
continues to evolve and get even more
virulent even more aggressive and delta
is an example of really a huge step
change in its ability to infect people
and so with that step change what you're
seeing is really more rapid breakthrough
and i think that is the surprising thing
from our perspective is that the
durability of the first couple of shots
is is really only looking to be maybe
six months maybe a year
now that's not
terribly surprising that you would need
a third dose i think as dr hahn said in
the other lead in you know that happens
with tetanus that happens with your flu
shot every year that you need to boost
yourself to maintain high levels of
protective immunity but i think we were
all hopeful that we were going to be
able to stop this thing with the initial
couple of doses and it looks like the
virus is going to fight back and require
booster doses more broadly certainly by
the fall
so i want to look at really the
conversation taking place in the
medical research
community right now and part of that
conversation has to do with
comparing the leading vaccines this is a
study
which was
reviewed by the mayo clinic and what it
shows us is that while both vaccines
were highly effective during the period
from january to june
six months later in terms of the seventh
month that's july
the numbers actually drop considerably
and what you have is effectiveness
against infection uh considerably lower
from the 90 percent uh at modernity goes
down to 75 percent but look at what
happens to the pfizer drug it drops all
the way down to 42 percent this study
suggests that the moderna
vaccine is superior to the pfizer
vaccine i recognize that this is not
peer-reviewed we are awaiting peer
reviews here but what can you tell us
about this study
well first caveat is that you know
maduro's not involved in the study we
weren't a sponsor it's independent or
searched by the folks at mayo clinic but
i think you summarized it well it there
is emerging evidence from this study and
other sources that there is a difference
in the durability of protection
particularly in the face of the delta
variant
at about six months between the two
different vaccines that are otherwise
very similar i think this is consistent
with the public comments by both of the
companies about their phase three trials
recently as well as some other
publications internationally including
from the governments in canada showing a
slight difference in protection over
time
i think the one last thing i'd want to
say about it though is that while while
there isn't yet maybe scientific
consensus around this and really that's
not the purview of any company that's
the general scientific community
even if there is a difference here and
the modern vaccine is showing better
durable protection against the
deltavarium we don't expect that will be
permanent and the truth is as you
pointed out there is a little bit of
waning already for moderna even though
it looks better it is trending down and
we suspect that over time maybe it's at
a year maybe it's it longer you will see
eventual increase in breakthrough cases
even with the best vaccines which is
again why we think ultimately boosters
are the best way to maintain broad
population immunity so we can stop the
pandemic stop the economic disruption
certainly stop the death
if you'd if you had two shots of the
pfizer can you do the modern booster
shot or do you have to stick with the
same
well that's really a decision for
regulators and public health officials
to make as a company uh we we will
generate data and we are conducting
clinical studies actually exactly on
that with the national institutes of
health as well as governments
internationally to try and provide
information that shows you can do that
but again the choice of whether that's
appropriate is really up to the fda and
the united states the cdc
and and dr hogue you i know that moderna
has been developing working on mrna
technology for 10 years this is
something that this company has been
focused on and you are also looking to
apply that to other illnesses such as
other respiratory
disease as well as cancer tell us a
little about that how you might be able
to tap into mrna technology for other
uses
yeah thank you for that we we actually
well known for our work here at govit
but but for the last 10 years we've been
working on the technology platform to
try and address all those diseases you
just referenced if you look at the
history of respiratory disease yeah our
view for for most of the last decade has
been we need to do so much better in
preventing the death every year that
happens as a result of infections like
flu or the common cold viruses that
often actually lead to silent death in
this country and internationally so
we've been working hard on developing
solutions for that you know hopefully
single vaccination the single injection
that you can get that protect you
against all of the viruses now including
covet 19 that actually lead to that
death and disability but we've actually
obviously
substantially pivoted to focus on covet
19 for the last year but we haven't
stopped that work and we're in the
process of starting late stage studies
across a range of those other
respiratory viruses and then the same
sorts of things using mrna to educate
your immune system something you can do
with cancer and so we're running
clinical trials right now in cancer
trying to show we can teach your immune
system what your cancer looks like
individual in per person's cancers so
that your immune system can attack it
and hopefully reverse the spirit of that
disease as well
amazing amazing thank you very much dr
stephen hogue we'll be watching the
developments we appreciate your time
this morning
we will see you soon